the movie and the book Jurassic Park
might have been science fiction but at
its core there was a credible premise
what if you could use a science of DNA
to resurrect long extinct creatures that
once roamed the earth
well efforts to do just that are
actually underway and one is detailed in
the new book Willy the true story of the
quest to revive one of history's most
iconic extinct creatures the book is
published by a tree of books an imprint
of Simon & Schuster a division of CBS
and it comes out next week it too is
being made into a movie we're joined by
its author Ben Mezrich Ben good morning
thank you very much you've you've
written about a lot of cool stuff you
say this is the coolest thing you've
ever wrote this is by far the coolest
thing bringing back the woolly mammoth
he's gonna be back in a few years we're
gonna have a woolly mammoth baby if all
goes well and how are they doing this
well you know you're the woolly mammoths
are coming up out of the ice
so the permafrost that is slowly getting
warmer these bodies are coming out and
they're taking the genetic material and
then they are synthesizing it and
they're placing into into the cells of
an Asian elephant so that an Asian
elephant gives birth to a woolly mammoth
so essentially you're recreating the
mammoths using its relative that still
exists today when you say they write
ways they I know that one of the main
figures in the book is Professor George
shirt right it's so leading the effort
here dr. Church I idolized him he is
basically the Einstein of our times he
is on the forefront of this revolution
going on in genetics where we've moved
from just reading our genes you know
figuring out what makes us us to being
able to write genes
so he's runs a lab at Harvard Medical
School it's a huge lab it's like Willy
Wonka's factory where they're making
transgenic mosquitoes to beat malaria
and mice to beat Lyme disease and
working on reverse aging and then the
woolly mammoth project is this really
cool project where the goal is like a
moonshot to make a woolly mammoth to
save the world what do you mean by that
see right well this is where it gets
really
so the the permafrost which is this
frozen tundra that's like the ring of
the world it's a ticking time bomb
it contains within it more carbon than
if we burned all the forests on earth
three times and these Russian scientists
the Z moths have shown since the 80s
that if you repopulate it with
herbivores from the police de'cine era
and they're using tanks to mimic woolly
mammoths and they're putting bytes in
there they've managed to lower the
temperature of the tundra by 15 degrees
so the goal is to put a herd of woolly
mammoths in the Siberian tundra to keep
the permafrost from melting Wow that's
why specifically they picked the woolly
mammoth well I mean the woolly mammoth
you know is is is iconic it's a moonshot
project this same technology can be used
to do incredible things but the mammoth
itself can actually help the world it's
an outside-of-the-box way what is this
open the door to if they play if they
pull this off well you know the genetic
engineering involved is the same genetic
engineering that's going to be used to
make all sorts of things you know
mosquitoes to beat malaria reverse aging
you know they're working on projects to
make our kids generation live 150 years
it's the same technology that allows us
to monkey with our own genes so there's
you know fears of designer babies of
things like that but the reality is this
is there's so many good things that can
come from this I mean elephants don't
get cancer which is very strange
elephants have thousands and thousands
and more cells than us and why they
don't get cancer is in their genes if we
can figure that out you can use this
genetic engineering to solve cancer okay
Ben you and you say with a wave of the
hand designer babies and forth but Gina
I think is a fairly controversial fairy
country there is there is a debate about
whether this is the ethical path for us
absolutely that's human being you know
nobody hates the woolly mammoth
but the gene the genetic engineering
used to make a woolly mammoth there are
definitely concerns on either side I
mean the idea of playing God the idea of
making a mistake of letting something
out of the lab these things come out and
that's why you need responsible
scientists dr. George Church is
incredibly a good person and you need
people like that doing this because this
this box is open yeah Pandora's box of
this technology
here there are labs all over the world
not just making woolly mammoths but
doing things that 10 years from now
we're going to have huge repercussions
so we want responsible scientists doing
this remind us of the size of a woolly
mammoth woolly mammoths are big you know
10 feet high their tusks are huge a
single tusk is worth a quarter million
dollars they're coming out of the ice
now they're giant you know they're about
1/3 bigger than an elephant and they
have the red hair and and and but
they're there they're loving wonderful
warm animals the book is Willie Ben
Mezrich thank you so much for being with
us this morning absolutely fascinating